so you're you're hanging out in
Minneapolis you're meeting everybody now
Jill are you there yet hmm
now you were you started you were
singing with Tina Marie mm-hmm I was and
I was and when did when did you meet
Prince um I met Prince when we were
touring we just come off of this the
Rick James tour and that was kind of
yeah and then we transferred somehow
over onto the 1980 what was it dirty
mind tour and that's how I met Prince on
that tour we were opening for him and I
think our stage was about a size of like
this size and I remembered running into
him in the hallway and I wasn't happy
about the size of the stage and I'm not
even the lead singer it was Tina but of
course I have a really big mouth I'm
sure if you know that but I kind of
that's how we met in the hallway and I
was just like what are we supposed to
pile on top of each other and play and
he was standing there looking at me like
I mean I wouldn't move and he was like
who are you lovers like Tina singer and
you know we just can't play because
really literally you know you're the
opening act but from that point we
started running into each other
we shared cars to the gigs and we kind
of stayed in touch over the years and
then somehow ended up back and I got
back to Minneapolis what was your first
impression dirty minds what was he
wearing
um underwear right leg warmers right
these are really short boots with some
kind of fringe a trenchcoat rights hair
was kind of like weirdly greasy weird or
something and my mom was the Tina's
torment like she was her manager and I
was still some so stubborn I was not
going to give it to him about cuz I was
still I think it was a little bit
rattled by meeting him and it just
became the issue was the stage but my
mom was like why don't you want to see a
show I said I just can't I just think
this is terrible and she was like you
know I was like 18 or
17 she's like you think this is this is
like your era and I'm and she goes he's
gonna be a huge star one day and I said
I don't know I just don't see it I
remember like I just don't see it cuz he
really unnerved me at a really strong
presence and I was a kid I what did I
know I was when did you when did you did
you finally listen oh yeah before I was
never gonna give in and tell anybody
that I really secretly liked it I was
always gonna be like you know curmudgeon
that's like completely me um you know I
don't ever want to jinx things okay
now Rob you knew him before did you know
him when he was a young man I had no
prints from the age my age of about 12
years old that's what I figured
right yeah yeah now you grew up in the
same neighborhood same neighborhood same
high school um he came to our high
school we had a high school in
Minneapolis called north community high
school we had one of the best music
departments in the city so all the
musicians would come to our school after
school and jam and even if they didn't
go to the school during the day the
school was open to to the community and
he lived in a community as well right oh
well was this this is the Grand Central
era before that this was before that you
know everything was coming together back
then we had so many bands back there in
the city at any time you could walk
through the neighborhood at night and
music will be blaring out the basements
now tell me this because this would
happen in our neighborhood y'all would
walk to the other block and listen to
the window from the basement to spy on
the other bands to see what they were
playing oh we weren't spying
you weren't spying now we still good for
the other folks were spying on you then
that's right all right now when you
first met Prince when he first of all
what was your impression of him we got
big old head
but he could play and he is saying and
he always had presence he's always he
always acknowledged me even as a young
kid and the amazing thing is that he
always had that respect for me I'm not a
musician my brother was so maybe you
know that respect trickled down from my
brother to me thank God no wood Joe just
play with Joe hang out - we hung out no
we played very hung out when we played
together right you know where there were
a lot of gigs that were put together
because a lot of the black groups
weren't allowed to play a lot of clubs
so you know Terry Jay would put together
battle of the bands and we were playing
music festivals in town and scuse me but
those who don't know when he refers to
his brother used to mope Terry Lewis of
Jimmy Jam and Terry Lewis
not just any Terry yeah am and for
clarity when you blog he's not a half
brother no brother right Bob but um they
would they would have battle of the
bands you know Andre Prince and Morris
was in a band Terry
Jimmy Jam jelly bean Monte Alexander
O'Neal Cynthia from lip-sync I want to
take you to funky town
Greg Robin Greg Williamson from Baywatch
was in the band amazing singer
we had an amazing horn section we would
we imitated p-funk cameo everything and
Princess Bam was very original Oh
original